un invierno que desafiará la
supervivencia la Organización Mundial de
la Salud advirtió que Las bajas
temperaturas amenazarán la vida de
millones de ucranianos esto luego de
estimar que al menos el 50% de la
infraestructura energética del país ha
sido destruida por los ataques rusos lo
que deja pronósticos alarmantes
Esperamos que entre dos y tres millones
de personas adicionales abandonen sus
hogares en busca de calor y seguridad se
enfrentarán a desafíos de salud únicos
que incluyen infecciones respiratorias
como el Kobe 19 neumonía influenza y un
riesgo grave de difteria y sarampión en
una población insuficientemente
inmunizada
desde que inició la Guerra hace casi 9
meses se han registrado más de 700
ataques contra hospitales y centros de
salud de Ucrania lo que representa una
violación al derecho internacional Según
denunció la OMS por otro lado detalló
que el conflicto le generará
enfermedades como estrés agudo ansiedad
depresión y trastorno postraumático a
unos 10 millones de ucranianos las
ciudades del país tienen constantes
cortes de energía y la mayoría se
encuentran sin suministro de gas por lo
que el gobierno evacúa a los residentes
principalmente en la región de miko Life
y la recién recuperada ciudad de gerson
nos vamos ahora porque da miedo dormir
por la noche esperaremos hasta que la
situación mejore y luego volveremos a
casa
nadie quiere salir de sus hogares pero
nos aconsejaron irnos para ahorrar
energía Y dejarla para los que están
luchando por Ucrania entonces este video
podemos usar las autoridades pidieron a
quienes viven en el extranjero que no
regresen a Ucrania durante el invierno
para conservar la energía y destinar la
hospitales y otras instalaciones clave